well metro is out with its state of the  department sheriff joe lombardo spoke  about the overall strategic plan  at the department he also spoke briefly  about vaccinating officers  while metro isn't mandating officers or  employees to get the vaccine  he is encouraging that everyone get it  when possible  he also spoke about the department's  budget the sheriff says about 30 percent  of the budget comes from sales tax  and with lower tourism numbers during  the pandemic the department  is taking a hit sales tax has a big  swing  and that's where we're affected the most  and that's where we hired  the majority of our police officers  hopefully i don't eat my words on this  but i don't anticipate  any pay cuts and i don't anticipate any  additional layoffs  sheriff lombardo says the department is  largely relying on federal stimulus to  help them along  and believes there is light at the end  of the tunnel